and welcome to this week's Android
developer office hours I'm in London
with liquid sure hello I'm Matthew
Vaughn here I to answer your Android
developer kind of technical questions
around Android and talk about the
Android operating system in general
things that we won't be talking about
include product roadmaps future releases
and stuff that you know we're not
supposed to talk about before you got
quite a full hang out today as one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
I think we're absolutely fall in fact
absolute n is the maximum weight yeah
we're in we have all ten people into the
story if you didn't get in straight away
maybe as people ask their questions and
we answer them they can drop out and
some other people will be able to get in
a little later ah still hoping we can
get spike in from our Munich office as
he's generally a bronze with the
subscribe today hey bruh nice to see or
not see you as the case may be because
Sparky has the answers to the questions
generally so it's quite good if he comes
in let me just repost this onto the
Android developers Plus page I still
lived in LA all right let me add the
moderator to the Android developers
first phase so that people know where
they thought that makes today's
moderator if anyone has any questions on
the Hangout whilst we're just sorting
this out at the very beginning please
feel free to start asking well I've got
one in same you know if jellybean you
added many male out here languages to a
android operating system to the Nexus
say to the Galaxy Nexus anyhow and out
those languages now belong to the base
languages that come to every device so
is it depended on on the feeling of the
OEM yep say say Moses we always give me
telling us a question for office I don't
know if the update no I know with jelly
bean a maybe change agents though not so
the same as always like we put out a set
image but it it's up to the carriers and
OEMs to choose what they think their
image the which language is actually
finally make it through is is up to
weather
bill well you did a really good job you
a job with people anyhow you know I've
been learning with it with quite a while
it's nice job excellent with it with Jay
only yeah it's pretty nice fantastic
okay well managed has been dying to get
this question in from before the
broadcast started so let's have a quick
look at manish's question ah i have a
problem i unzipped a zip file on the SD
card and after unzipping got CSV and
then important CS being sick like I had
talked a lot your information I want to
tell you I'm gonna hide things that may
help me please is that question I think
he's asking how to import CSV into a
sequel life after under thing is the svn
puts us in civil life and we saw the
canned answer for how to pre prepare
sequel like databases is a really good
answer on Stack Overflow that I will
plan and add into the links but there's
a couples of ways of doing it you can
either pre-prepared the database as a
sequel like three database file using
adb shell and things like this or you
can be the import support import
afterwards employee new sequel like
database on the device not sure that's
going to take a little bit of time and
you'll have some duplicated data let me
just pull off the stack overflow link
and add it into the comment essentially
what you're doing is going again reading
the file right and creating content
valuations inserting them into your into
your database yourself
yes you do I'm not certain I computer
that I'm sure we'll find this pretty
quickly well looking up there not
because our screen is a thousand inches
and actually I can just drag stuff or
whatever because all the questions
appear on the screen that's up in the
sky sunlight and that's where my line is
attached to the wall that's where our
web browser lives as well crime as you
detect Narcisa militias other question
where's Sparky Sparky and it's trying to
join at the moment he's just having a
few technical issues and hopefully he'll
jump in to hang out soon if there's
still this has the nipple question which
I also know the answer to what happened
to Todd's hair what happens to arias
where the answer to that is day I'll me
that's what happened yummy i love so
much yeah question about the monkey re
has a question whoa RSS is trying to
create the automated two-way process
with android devices monkey run i've
been searching a lot over the web it
seems to me that you know the number one
expert on this happy since that's not
really sorry people watching on the live
stream this is quite a long question i
have been able to run successfully the
monkey runner through the command and
loading a pike and I was tasting more
and more as we go ah I finally the big
hassle to connect to the device has
returned I want to run a command is that
any way I can do this without letting
for the bicycle time ah we do have quite
a good testing guide inside the new
developer android com site it has
updated the description on how to use
monkey run so if you haven't checked it
in the last three or four weeks it might
be useful for you I don't have a
specific answer to how to keep the
device connected so you got after cute
ah
we're connecting to other monkey runs it
sounds strange that it's disconnecting
well compute anyone else got any
expensive monkey running it can offer
anything here yeah we happy I've only
ever seen disconnects when it's running
out memory on the actual device itself
from the firmware starts to fail I've
not seen it with a generally well
written application bailing as it should
without any issues so it might be worth
looking over the application just in
case there are some memory leaks or
things like that which could be eating
up the RAM on the device good answer
alright so still collating spots join
and I've gotta create that come on
Charles them before heading for you yeah
sure it's just it's to do with the
navigation navigating within the stack
so the appointment we have is we've
recreated a widget and the user touches
their part of the widget which takes the
user into the app sort of a deep link
within the app so our question is with
regard to sort of what happens when hit
the back button at that point once
you've navigated into the app and so
it's probably helpful to give an example
so the YouTube app when you you have a
youtube widget you hit a video it takes
you to the video obviously with them you
to go interesting me when you head back
it takes you back to the to the launch
activity but if you have the gmail
widget for example you hit an email it
takes you into the email within gmail
but if you at the back here takes you to
the inbox list so cut the question I
guess is what is the X what is the
recommended behavior look see nothing
watching melting I think a general
approach the way I remember at least is
and because you can resume an order
activity and so on is you don't want to
think about exactly where you kind of
come focus eat your user could resume
that you know the human activity at any
time and if they were to hit the back
button it will take them hoping that
would be like an unexpected behavior so
the key is that if there's a usual place
you would get to that screen from
backbone to take you there so the task
but backs tech bold or whatever it's
called doesn't actually doesn't work pre
three-point not they just sort of um as
far as I'm aware doesn't actually
support piece 3.9 yeah there's a version
in the support library so that's one
point six okay so that will work i'll
have the same behavior back to 1.6 yeah
okay and i'll take a look at that thanks
you know there's two things you can take
a look at that and the thing that helps
you at the navigation is in in 4.1 jelly
bean this a new attribute on activity
where you can define the parent yeah so
the the sport Larry will help you out
there as well you obviously in n come
back with compatibly change activity but
that you can add a metadata tag which
defines the parent so you know whatever
the metadata tag adaptivity say much
parent it is if you take a look at the
google i/o app and from this year and
that's a great example of how to you had
to do this ok thanks welcome put that
one we have multiple parents want 250
other parent not had a parent with it as
long as you specify each yeah lovely
tune you it is helps the app button do
the right thing
any more live questions from people in
the hang up okay nice take the first one
off the top of the moderator that is
there an implementation of the content
provider that returns a cursor of plain
old java objects actually a cursor
implementation that contains objects oh
there's not one that I know about did he
just die or something did London a full
yeah London have just fallen off well I
guess the back again yeah okay someone
kicked the cable or something we lost it
just after you said they were there
wasn't a content provider implementation
you knew about warningly open source of
the third kind of man does anyone on the
Hangout node one I guess I hope that
bill you post the question would have
shirts the Internet's or at first but at
the same time it's not particularly hard
to go from sequel light to PO Jones in
your instantiation afterwards you take
it later and they'll give you again
there are a few object relational
mapping tools as well that can take a
lot of that heavy work and do it for you
if you has a look around there'll be
some around that
we bought Sparky with us this time hey
Sparky Dixie hey it's good to be here Oh
inside your desk in the Munich office
right now that is my desk in the Munich
office you and your big club well as you
know as you know the new version of Mac
OS mountain lion ship today and my my
macbook being too full versions of the
OS behind is beset with such feelings of
inadequacy and anxiety that it refuses
connect to connect on anywhere less
network in the office so I had to go to
a place where I have a wired network how
come you're not using your phone that's
why I keep that one at home no
interesting we have the choice I thing
London died again yeah we think the
Sparky be hitting the London drop out
every few minutes or so so ah why I
think I think our network went the same
place the tall's hair went yeah what if
he's radiology alright so we've just
type of the first question off the top
of the moderator I Know Nothings it a
common pattern RT is always to have a
blind method on your page 0 which
accepts the cursor say you can a nice
hey user cursor what's the spot cursor
you must be looking at moderator
questions I haven't seen yet it's just a
new on the side it in that's okay we're
uh we're on it all right we have Richard
Thompson welcome hands I don't know I
don't know why we're still in here twice
so now you must rotate the next
moderator question Sparky sure ah you
just did to do to this really cuz uh I'm
Joe objects if there any implementation
of a content provider returns cursor a
POJO object that was just done I am way
behind you guys oh there we go now I see
it that's a good one you got a tard I no
question since the last time I connected
crazy oh yeah
that one's not even at the top of my
list have you looked at the sea JDM
question no yeah all right Matt from
Warwick wants to know with CTV I'm being
deprecated are there any chances any
change is anticipated for how cloud
messaging GCMs implemented in the future
about google cloud Messing's of primary
method or can we rely on GM for the
foreseeable future well my crystal ball
is a little bit overcast today but I
would guess that that at the very least
GCM will be no less stable than to
device messaging was which is that we
ran it for a couple of years and then
give it a nice graceful exit strategy
with giving people lots of time to
change over to the new method and at the
very least I think you can expect at
least that level of support for Google
Cloud messaging as well it seems at the
moment that the Google Cloud messaging
is quite active because every week or 2
i'm seeing public announcements about
new features being added and tweaks
being made but seems pretty active from
what I'd seen yeah well I
cloud-to-device messaging c2dm basically
went into future freeze several months
ago and all the new development has been
taking place in GCM and i have several
significant advantages over ccd Emma's
all right let the fan out and so on yeah
and not least of which is that you don't
have to request quarters anymore not
only do not have to request Buddhist we
want to sign up for an account either
you just you publish your app and right
pull this whole off login client our
client login to step to get your server
side messaging we just give you an API
key that you can use so so this this
whole login process that your server has
to do is no longer the case your side of
interest you do you know why we
allow space for three sender IDs
application no so the reason I heard is
if you have three different kind of like
topic streams or something like that and
you might be able to do that like food
service in the air mistress yeah huh I
did wonder I'm not buying that I think
one is enough one for all your apps but
yeah s Bucky says an Elmo feed them it's
been actively developed so if you are
developing on any half feedback then
make sure you send it through I mean he
can spray that virus or and was named
for its good Nelly is it the gym yeah
you're fat rascal I jestli that's it now
he's cool and he's he is quite active
again the Android c2dm forum wasn't he
also on the state side office hours last
week yes he was there might be worth
they've someone's looking city boo Cloud
messaging having a look at the stateside
officers from last week and seeing what
he said in that I know I don't know why
we keep dropping out songs but a time
bomb inside a machine essential
everybody's trying to download mountain
lion know those it's like a it's a it's
network bandwidth reservation for the
Olympic Committee the other night
intellect type as well now they're
laying on the important success you
cannot say any more than Olympic
Committee any more words and you'll be
in trouble with the branding police bar
cubes are staffed Samuel in the G+ post
is asking is there a cinch gplus States
that's what if I style slide in
drop-down menu the one that I've seen so
far is too
latios he now he has no Nico exhaust and
he has a series of articles talking you
through some of the techniques you use
so there are a bunch of them open source
implementations I think there's one on
github ribbon menu which looks pretty
nice there was one there's a couple of
major threads on stack overflow just
search worth there yeah see if I can
find it oh yes at the moment you're done
already and custom layout or using
someone else's hmm trail make his way
into green your way to some point or
another refresh this scene it just yet I
shall take another question from the
moderator yeah sure will there be an API
or SDK to provide custom cards for
Google now I don't know I would be
slaver us out of here that we won't be
talking back apart for a map feature
releases definitely not an outside
absolutely be questioned definitely
falls into that I don't then that makes
me really eager to take the next one
from the moderator which is google maps
and speech recognition got offline
functionality lately is there any way to
leverage these within our own apps I
don't know that's what I've heard I'm
Thomas E right not that I i had thought
so at least in the case of the speech
recognizer not last i would i wasn't
able to turn up any solid information
confirming that yeah google maps through
anything you can do there and speech
recognition is transparent if there
isn't any network it'll use the offline
one ugly the user can also select
preferential i think they might be some
cases were offline that you didn't
present like a charity that the actual
results of that surprisingly good yes a
very multi network so if you have some
connectivity but it's kind of low
bandwidth or yeah hyping time wearing
something they will yeah to all over to
the offline try and give you the best
experience possible
as a user yeah whole point the speech
interactions first be fast right like
that if you have to sit around waiting
for long times it's pretty useless so
try to avoid that can I add something as
we're talking about speed and latency
and audio I am experiencing some
troubles with the media player when I'm
trying to play a pee file it only placed
first few milliseconds or so and it's
not it's not reproducible so it has
something to do with the mark a I use at
the same time or something not very sure
about this so maybe you could say
something about that um the media player
has quite a complex life cycle have you
read all the documentation on it make
sure that you're following the the
threat life cycle for the stream if it's
not fully prepared and you've got the
callback saying the strings prepared and
then you hit run on it you are going to
run into that kind of problem yeah so
I've got some method to override we're
fully loads to the thingy and then
starts birth okay i just think that even
when it you do get the error it's
already come back and said the videos
ready to go and then it tries to play it
let's still falls apart yeah okay do you
have any stack traces or any actual
errors that come out of it or is it
there's nothing left at all no I
actually don't get any things I'm at in
my locker iana stole my mic cable just
broke so I can't test it in Miami later
because we can't shake the emulator and
yeah so I just this tomorrow shaking you
later no can you why don't shake it ah
why do you want to well our guy in my
coder I've gotta shake listener so i use
it on the pole and I should implement
something to just like emulator shake
with the little button or something's up
no no no I cannot check the emulator but
you still need a cable for it anyway the
latest version of the emulators allowed
us in census from the device into the
emulator but ok able you haven't got
cable you must have a healthy way these
nickels is that just me absolutely that
might
USB cables not just the guys open
intense also have a sense of simulator
which I think may be able to rip that
emulate a shake on a device with an
emulator so i'll put the link up for
that iphone gonna stack overflow to post
air as well well you know i had one
comment about jelly bean that's you know
it's really you can see that it's much
faster the next year by only comment
again this year when you have two phone
apps like for example the devil's own
app and skype you require to place a
different buttons just to make a phone
call which you know it's really annoying
because you it was it used to be two and
now it's free ya know we tell you this
that point because we dropped out again
well my point was about jelly bean and a
few buttons if you've got it to phone
apps just to make the phone for example
if you've got a the phone normal phone
app and skype oh you mean they always in
just one style yeah I'm can pick up yeah
this idiot yes you're indeed it's a bit
annoying if you see what I mean that I
have to press three different buttons
just to make a yes to dial a number yeah
they always behaviors fine but just once
behavior is somewhat in like I agree if
you use that on what I wanted by the
difference with browser than you know
like with skype in normal phone calls
I'll you know it's for different use
cases while the buzzer is usually for
the same case if you see what I mean
normally I don't know when you just set
the phone to always and then why because
sometimes I call a broad and koala
bought from Israel is quite expensive so
I you skype and it's much cheaper in
skype then let me say
so I wouldn't be surprised that changed
at some point but uh I don't actually
know but when it used to be two buttons
and now its face so you know there's
certainly been quite a few conversations
about that application selection dialog
at first what well the other thing that
you know it this day they improved about
it is switching between keyboards
because it used to that you have to
place a long press on the middle space
button in order to switch and now you've
got this globe button that you can just
press on it and it switches the cube
instead of having a pop up to doing some
loose on with keystroke don't need
everyone so what but you know it's
getting too yeah uh where are we Sparkie
oh I think you're going to meet Lance
paki wow she wants on you okay you know
crack okay um yeah there's a couple of
questions on moderator but actually know
the answers to I think one is I'm
building an after includes a live audio
stream I want to use rtsp this is
supported on all android OS versions i
can't speak to all but I've seen forum
posts talking about it way back in the
days before cupcakes so I would sort of
tentatively say yes um I've got a little
bit info on this one right so we were
playing around with getting some rtsp
streaming going move we tested I think
up to honeycomb like a belief media
player does work on it but if you're
expecting it to just be a completely
live stream there is buffering on the
media player I think you can get around
so as far as I'm aware it is supported
but there is that kind of slight latency
in terms of buffering cetera and the
official page says the following network
protocols water does ESP could it be
that it's a codec issue as much as rtsp
support yeah it's we would try to
new extremes
well they were in the right format so I
mean the obvious example to try and make
sure you've got it right which is a bit
of a nasty way of doing it but yeah is
getting interviewed for VLC t divided
mitchell the actual stream is valid and
the right codec and then if it's a case
of that actually does work then yeah you
guys to dig deeper and also post the
official supportive media collect and
streams there is a page in the developer
documentation about it which does
suggest way to say LTS peer supported
and it says that page 263 is probably
only format mp4 or 3gp that's supported
throughout all versions of Android as
well is it possible on mobile devices
for OEMs to add extra codex yeah yes and
some flood though bicycle that's because
I know that what happened to Google TV
say yeah take the licenses yeah how'd
the women if you make sure you're using
them before if i'll make sure it's set
up in the proper streaming format so you
need to make sure that some of them i
think the move Adam needs to be before
any of the data atoms as well which is
pretty standard thing so you can check
the extremes in the right format should
we take them off from the moderator yep
this way I with preferences activity
being deprecated and preference
fragments and I become available
starting with AK 11 is it recommended to
check and you see the new API available
or just wave the support library catch
up I don't know exactly about the
support library there's a partial answer
from Gabriel ignorant Germany that says
he doesn't think performance preference
regmont can be added to the library due
to some internal dependencies I can't
really speak to that but in my own
experience there's only just a few lines
of difference between a preference
activity in a preference fight
so I would probably do is try to factor
that into its own encapsulate the code
and just call it from either the
activity or the fragment depending on
what you what you do tech support for
that's that's my recommendation I tested
this a little bit for example and I can
you can read the same XML fragment you
know the same XML parcel in either one
in the same application in a rest is
fine given that although we've
deprecated it reference activity still
works I kind of have a hard time telling
people no don't use that just use
nothing I mean it's the without it being
in the support library you can't access
it on gingerbread which means you can't
access them on something like you know
sixty to ninety percent of the devices
out there and I'm reluctant to give that
advice so I would say go ahead and do
the do the dual implementation method
it's not that much extra work there's an
interesting thread on the action bar
Sherlock issue tracker that covers this
and covers the reasons why it's unlikely
to make it into the support library as
well so i'll put a link up to that in
case anyone wants more info see okay
anything else we're inside the Hangout
Before we jump to the next moderator
question
okay like stuffed on the moderator is
there a way to call the recognizer
intent and have it return a result no
matter what and not show the error
message or connections areas and such
probably not but I don't know computers
to catch that yeah I I don't I don't
yeah I don't know about the recognizer
intent I would say if it does return
error codes probably not a way to
suppress those I suppose you could have
a try again you know put it in a bag
async task or something but I don't know
of a way to I mean I haven't looked into
the API but a priori I don't know of a
way to force it to return the result
well the api doc says he returns the
intent or just now if not available so I
guess the problem is you're calling
recognizer intent the UI is coming up
with a lot microphone in it and let the
pulsing trying to recognize if there's
no connection the end the users can get
an arrow that they have to dismiss and
then it goes back to the the app with
just a non-response so it's calling
functionality in another part of the
system then trying to control that and
yes my lord says there's no extras you
can add on to the recognizer intent they
certainly aren't any specified in the
documentation which would allow you to
say if there's no connection then don't
show it they get the healthiest thing to
do would be to check connectivity before
you call the recognizer intent and if
there isn't connectivity don't give the
option to the voice recognition although
of course that change the jellybean
anyway where we have offline voice
recognition so later you're saying
you're on ice cream challenge or before
and there's no connection then don't
show the recognizer option might be a
reasonable solution to your problem
and then the next one is how do i get
the galaxy nexus one nexus s to emulate
an unencrypted tag I wonder if you're
trying to do it programmatically or if
you just want to do it as a test of the
device if you just want to emulate a tag
you can download the NXT software out of
the play store and you can read and
write tags or pretend to be tags and do
things like that and this is a pretty
complex subjects wary depends on what
the tag type is because we really
support one particular tag type which
like when I know and I wish I feel the
name of hand with the micro no no we
don't support my fur and it's an iso
standard one that we support but yeah
it's a really really quite conflict
situation so it's quite open-ended let's
say it depends on what the tag if I am
emma is we got but yeah okay yeah we'll
probably your best at your best bet
they're trying to do that and even if
you're trying to do something else nxp
has an advanced mode for debugging which
is just excellent for trying to sort any
of these issues out and see what
contents of tags and what format tags
are in things like that so glad that out
of the play store you have anything else
on the country
ah
so I added mix recommendation to my
answer there sure are some reason to
Android pose can I do I so 1443 dash 40
and what their classic so I not not the
standard my besties or not they can do
mifare classic yeah that's what we see
hopefully the person who is asking that
question yes he's trying to emulate
anything else no then you might be out
of luck open my coaches watching the
video vixen or later so next question is
how can we must be a cop manager an
Android Texas currently the Duvall
constructors private I need to add a mac
account manager I have not gone into the
depths of what you can walk and when I
can't mark in the test so I can't really
speak to that I could look it up but I
have not done so in advance yeah I got
that's a new but the question did look
it up
it seems to be some answers on the
android google group which may or may
not work I was just checking that out
and having a search we don't have the
central comment on whether there will be
one in the future as we don't know for
more through this page to be did you
cover the question about the lights
making the phone out or tablet friendly
now that's what we had to go through
this 11th annual ice fishing for example
I want to make my apps apps more tablet
friendly so how do I keep a phone layout
for phones all since they large images
when you use it in stores my tablet I
think that one's a complete stopper I
don't think we're going to be able down
to that 50 is that possible owes who
shadows the fun yeah well there's two
major ways you can do this so if you
need to have a like a completely
distinct layout and then that you can
just provided different layout using the
resource qualify on the layout directory
so you'd have your layout directory
containing your your your layout but for
phones and then you could have a layout
dash x large or say dash SW 600 for
example if you wanted to say I need a
minimum of six hundred DPS and so I
screen in order to show this large it
out and then you have an alternative
layer and they're the same name so
that's one way you have a different
layout so go and check the developer
doctor that and another technique which
are quite like as well as if you if the
same layout works well for both the
phones but no say I guides a nexus 7 you
want to have slightly larger images and
you can just use a dimensions file so
similarly in your in your values or you
might have a value at the men's the XML
in your values folder saying you know
the image size should be 100 DP but you
have an overloaded version in your
values dash S the music's the movie bit
and which which has a similar file but
overrides that values it says the image
I should be 150 DP so then when you come
and reference that size from your layout
you'll get the right version depending
on what device you're anyone's you can
use the same base layout but just add
bigger image sizes or text size
so whatever lazy might be sold of course
it very welcome in the docks as well if
you just search for supporting multiple
screen sizes that's right and you can
see all the details on that as well real
estate something this barking certainly
there we go I was going to say those
those size qualifiers those ice buckets
do those work on on alternative
drawables as well as on layouts I
thought they did but I'm not sure
dribles you do though densities right
well I trivially on our case on there as
well ually even that includes the screen
window please silver like if you install
to what you could do is I have you'd in
this size we should look at the
supporting multiple screen space yeah
yeah she's really the supporting
multiple screens which I think that's
going to be answer but before you would
have had dash X labs and then you can
have an epi HTTP iron etc etc and make
sure you get the order of those right as
well because do it is important there's
a high run and documented yes famous it
and if you don't want to look at the
documentation you can just add your
qualifiers using the graphical tool and
the in the IDE and your clips and it'll
put them in the right order for you
well I'm just looking through the
different qualifiers and you can even
specify the qualifier for the country
code to the mobile country code if you
want to have different graphics detected
by the country of the device
automatically you can put your MTC in
your country code in there just on
providing alternative resources or car
tires there's a lot of different
monetize now you are my car desk
television alone these are old these
will be nested swimming yeah okay I know
ignores the next one okay I think I'm on
so the next one of the moderator is sort
of a long complicated question from way
up and Greece says a lot of development
applets quite dynamic it has to
correspond to specific tables in a
database comes from a user account on
the website and we'll have to create
buttons and strings and stuff comes off
the web server I this sounds to me kind
of like your basic client-server
application you can probably use any
sort of a restful api renouncing its
soap or by using JSON or whatever i
don't i don't see that that there's
anything about this that doesn't fall
into a very broad category of
applications that we've seen on android
before so i think it's definitely doable
and probably involves quite a lot of
code
so the writer says is there a library um
no I don't think there might be some
other libraries but for anything this
complexity to be able to get around
writing a lot of code maybe you can use
some some techniques to accelerate your
database access food if you're having
databases on the device but yeah pretty
much you're talking client-server
application it's sort of a solved
problem nothing nothing groundbreaking
in there my most slovakia be in Street
View that's an application question at a
development question yeah the next two
questions are not entirely appropriate
application will feature requests like
salad and how can I get chrome on my
android the answer from the other reader
is supported on ICS and above and I'll
accept that as the correct answer yeah
yeah let's jingle okay which means I
believe we've got through the motorized
questions there's a question in the
cheapest Fred where Boyd asks says he
loves Holly theme so much can he use it
elsewhere yes oh no he's just going to
use it in on gingerbread apps and even
iOS or web apps and oh I would say
gingerbread not too hard because it's
you know if you've got all your XML
descriptors putting the whole thing to
iOS that sounds to me like a world of
pain I mean yes you can copy the
appearance but you can't actually port
the assets directly yeah i'm just gonna
be flipping over and i would say you can
yes lucky says you can probably get hold
of the assets and you know the general
padding and look and feel by looking in
the platform Resources directory but you
probably want to stop and think is that
you really want to do like a
big advocate of having apps that kind of
native on that platform that they're on
and I'm not going to say though that it
is okay for an actor that like follow
the holo theme on gingerbread even
though it's introduced after that
platform because I just think it's kind
of an unmanageable task to really keep
an app like looking completely native
and every version of Android out there
so if you're going to put any effort
into making you out look great I'd say
make it look work great on you know the
newest stuff on hollow and it's okay I
mean that's what we do Google if you
take a look at email application or play
store for example they're both very
hollow kind of themed application and it
look the same on gingerbread so you
definitely can do that and the other
hand turnabout is fair play isn't it
wouldn't have been nice to see an
application on iOS four once that a
clone of at Android version instead of
vice versa all the resources and stuff a
party android open source projects
that's all patchy license so there's
nothing stopping anyone going for that
when I can tell you that in his eye they
actually started there you know for
juicing apps on Android before they
start on iOS by this amazing we five
partners whose apt to be rejected from
the I West Dorcas epic to anybody before
you just don't get to see the Maya
West's they rejected before they land in
the store no no they didn't develop them
just because they'll delay today like
for example a big telephone company here
just for just a and AB the chose you
free Wi-Fi that belongs to the network
you know like does 02 and other
companies India and they said the iphone
iOS will come soon but the Android is
already out so it's completely Android
style I for iOS free whatsoever quite
surprisingly really yeah it's been about
six months or so since we launched the
Android design site and we see not just
you know Keane Android advocates and
developers but also at this the big
companies really starting to embrace
that and nothing but that's what they
long for is an official pricing this is
what an Android app looks like it and
people started father so it's pretty
entity mmm yeah
that would definitely push that I think
also you know android this week you know
I think the advantage of Android also
it's the fact that he has so many
varieties of devices as opposed to one
device if you see what I mean because
usually that's the way I said if you
look in a normal family it's very rare
that you've seen one family the same
device for all people in the family as
opposed to agree my referral no extra
same pretty sale I mean I've got an HTC
HD but that's got an exercise I've got a
Galaxy Nexus my brother it's got a
samsung galaxy s2 Android family all
different devices there you go beautiful
story well I ain't got a nexus s no I
wish good thing I've got one I can also
tell you right now you know they
announced at the time jellybean got a
started rolling out for the Exuma so
they just started it oh yeah about a few
hours ago they said the next da that
some people started getting it so right
so that's the Galaxy Nexus Nexus S
obviously the Nexus 7 and now the zoom
Wi-Fi the zoom Wi-Fi rollout is only a
preview it's not going out to the public
over the air it's part Motorola's early
adopter program and they're trying to
get people to test it before they do
live roll out baby yeah I doubt it this
is much wider pushing out to their
device is not the ones that Google
control the American Wi-Fi built America
of my favorite ever was being controlled
by Google isn't it motorola run a test
program before they released the stuff
across to google and they're running the
test program at the moment for the same
when i'm trying to install right now you
know I'm not part of the testicle but I
downloaded it many Orleans hopefully
I'll be able to start with the USB
anyway course you pushed onto us-1 up
they existed in our nexus 7 commercial
they were using an unlocked nexus 7 yeah
but where is the fun in that if you get
straight away without try to install it
yourself see you feel like you're in
control right and what about the Nexus
Nexus Q what version of a toy does that
run you know unlit space what did you
find yourself when you did running a
tweet person of ice cream sandwich so
404 lots of little changes in it because
it's Android at-home device city all
right excellent stuff um will keep the
video down at length a little bit this
time see if it increases and all of
YouTube videos i watch us later on so
thank you all very much for dropping by
today and we'll see you all again at 2pm
next week for the next Android developer
office hours thanks guys hey guys do you
say guys I have one one big pot of a
question can I just say I'm pressing the
button okay so I Chrome browser and when
they're select text grown things it's a
mouth gesture how do i turn it off
chrome bears are all android no I might
be sequel what there's no gestures in
chrome on your pc you just select text i
select text from right to left and it
takes me back a page I think you should
still don't numero oh yeah that that's
like an apple i'm also on the wheels
device i'm a HP probook oh why do you
need to go to the Chrome office hours at
us Roman will go off any extension
startin happen online yeah tell a few
extensions going to safe mode what if
it's called on dave mark okay it's fine
yes rumor that all right